it may look like a picturesque setting
for a calm serene day on the river but
this is one of the busiest illegal
trafficking routes in the world
day and night makeshift rafts cross the
river border between Guatemala and
Mexico it never stops
[Music]
they bring cargo loads of everything out
food weapons and drugs but also these
days the most precious and fought over
cargo of all humans there's a steady
stream of seemingly most are heading
north for the United States the majority
are escaping violent South and Central
American countries but there is now a
new previously unthought-of an
unexpected phenomena thousands upon
thousands coming from around the world
all traffic by ruthless multinational
people smuggling syndicate who use drug
cartels and crime gangs to protect a
business worth millions every week
[Music]
it's a chilly misty morning in Guatemala
the latest group of travelers hoping to
get to Mexico and the United States
gather at a secret location the group is
escaping the gang violence and poverty
of Nicaragua El Salvador and Honduras or
want to make a new start and they
believe that this is the best way their
journey is fraught with danger they're
being smuggled by a crime gang a
syndicate with a network throughout
South and Central America and stretching
right into the United States
this unmarked mountain crossing has
never been filmed before it's taken
months for Sky News to get permission
from the traffickers cartel bosses on
board our two young girls Daniela is 16
carla is 14 years old
I seem unaware how vulnerable they are
and how dangerous their trip is although
they admit they and their families are
concerned are you scared of this trip or
the family scared
si es nada por que es primera vez que VA
ho b familia
nikka Alibaba vez mas que voy a salir
porque voy a hos por que no se C no
puede volver
this is what has driven you to move and
you're very young so what has driven it
now
they go missing minutos aqui this is not
the name of para comer was in fall
telecommunication falta de niro please
go you ready videos a little then your
guard para para más adelante you to me
and say 'christopher kenya pero la
fourmi familia quiero here ok then I'm
gonna make her be this man is the
group's guide all the way to the United
States
they're called coyotes here's a gang
member crucially he has the phone
numbers and passwords to get faster
dozens of gangs that buy ahead of them
there is no guarantee any of them will
be safe CSS kucik in Mexico muy
peligroso
pero CASL trata con un hoyo de que tenga
contactos en todo Mexico muy problema
porque el coyote saber reportando con la
mafia UDC alpha Doral McGraw see oh no
no se todo classes delincuente hablando
con ellos para pagando viaje de cada
immigrant a de Guatemala para todos
Unidos Sally carro
porque si dinero low Bhangra partying
van pagando todo para que no
the simple fact is that almost all
people attempting this journey are
touched by violent crime in some form or
other robbery and assault are almost
guaranteed and the abduction of young
girls and their subsequent imprisonment
in brothels is so common that the crimes
aren't even investigated
[Music]
almost all of the girls working the
streets and the Mexican border town of
tap Achuar where virtually all migrants
pass started their professional lives
still dreaming of an ordinary life in
the United States Karolina is typical
she crossed the Mexican border trying to
get to the United States within minutes
though she was abducted by a man
offering her a lift it was the start of
a life of prostitution wandering gricean
la Frontera de Guatemala con Mexico
Philip Romero Khmer pass office lugar
you know Sevilla please you may when vmi
ito ay que pagar please
so hurry man okay lapa Garo al Tracey
Claro que pagar Joe I found my solo
routine and when you say you were sold
you arrived at a building and people
basically you were then imprisoned and
and you couldn't leave what had happened
hasta que pagar el dinero que the via
milk a cauliflower and have that have
you gone beyond that now you feel better
now
mask at all leave it leave it economy go
miss my equals don't which are like
olives forgetting all see who's in
soccer adelante learning I just a grande
para mula tango you're latina me mama
pero mosquito me siento Libra call me or
miss sukira when what Rama Hari see no
no Nadia Mason I'm Aragon yes yanti no
era see
[Music]
there's just a petula in southern Mexico
it's at the center of the trafficking
business
most new arrivals to Mexico pass through
here a myriad of cheap hotels where the
travelers await their next move
one of the largest of the new travelling
communities come from India Pakistan and
Bangladesh
there are five curry houses on this
street below each are paying between
30,000 and 50,000 dollars to the
smuggling syndicate the new arrivals get
an affectionate hug
despite the VIP costs the journey
through five or six countries to this
point has been horrendous
California 19 year old sim Ranjit says
he is traumatized by his trip with the
smuggling syndicate he was robbed by
both the military and the police and in
Panama watched as injured travelers were
executed and women again routinely raped
mafia has been fun
lots of weapon like gun sward they kill
if man
not survive in the jungle we've heard
women are attacked quite a lot did that
happen
the games were they great yeah in my
cargo mafia rape every girl who clothes
in the jungle the story though is not
unusual eight agencies say they've heard
it many times before what wasn't so well
understood until now is the size and the
sophistication of the smuggling
operation pammi another Indian on his
way to the United States says the
trafficking syndicate have operatives in
every country on the route of a network
of guys to transport the human cargo and
can buy off corrupt officials across
continents there are some little agents
in India and they also have contact in
Delhi and their daily people's have
contact in like other countries and
those are the man who control everything
there are 50 to 60
person under them they control them from
out of central Latin America I think so
that my agent is in Europe that he is
controlling in this all these things
from here all the agents who organized
the smuggling of people from all over
the world have developed close working
relationships with cartel bosses and
their gang members in over half a dozen
different countries along the route to
the United States but making contact
with them is difficult and dangerous
[Music]
Nogales in northern Mexico is over a
thousand miles north of the gathering
point for the international travelers in
Taba to the border fence stretches out
four miles on either side and right
through the center of Nogales families
split by the fence often meet at
weekends to say hello physically they're
just inches apart in reality they could
be split forever
[Music]
the ever-present sound in the railway
with trains passing across the border is
a reminder that legitimate traffic isn't
hampered by the fence to the right
contacts the illegal traffic isn't he
we're traveling to a secret location to
meet the people who make the crossing
possible they're part of the Sinaloa
cartel have asked powerful crime
organization they traffic people these
days that their business was founded on
drugs
they take both businesses very seriously
so if an armed guard always obviously
yeah you can see over here that the
store we just draws the call marijuana
doesn't stop if you want to see a subtly
where I got the success of the printed
smuggling operation is founded on the
now well-documented but nonetheless
staggering efficiency of the drug
cartels to move their product be it
marijuana cocaine heroin crystal meth of
people to its final destination so this
is Mexican yes
[Music]
it's a dangerous business the gang
members never stopped checking for
suspicious movement outside their
so-called warehouse a flat to you and me
the business depends on the link between
the various groups over vast distances
to coordinate the movement of the cargo
just as the Indian boys witnessed they
say that the they pay their and then
they passed from one person to another
person to another person or they come
all the way through from South America
from Central America you part of that I
mean you know they're coming yeah you
know these people are coming even from a
long time before yes because you know
like let's say you live in Guatemala
right you send me people to here so you
call me let me know so no I sent two
guys three four five guys
okay the people who went across to
Mexico and Chula Vista know when the mr.
Killa Chiapas so this is different guy
you know the they call me you know that
the device already so and then to when
get to Mexico and the different guy that
comes you know he's the people's in
Mexico so when you send it to Novalis is
later okay so it's really well okay yeah
for us seeing how they work is the key
we've been given permission to join a
smuggling operation it's mostly done on
foot it's the last bit of the journey by
car very sure they were going to be
dropped off and we're going to begin the
walk the car she only faces there's two
of the guys here are going to be going
across the border into the United States
all things being equal we have people
with us who are going to show us the way
and then we'll obviously come back it's
the first time they've let Outsiders in
and it's ever been filmed onboard a
somewhat terrified traveller is
preparing to jump
they want us to move quickly as the
night closes in this is a popular route
with competing gangs and they rent
access to the border by the hour in the
red and white shirt is Pedro a guide
known as coyotes wild desert dogs who
know the routes to the USA but is it
quite easy getting over hedgerow tells
me it's not easy as Salinas cameras and
Border Patrol's APIs
he'll gain near the board and house
while we've gone into night shots
getting very dark out here and they're
very very jumpy they keep checking
seeing people how many people of anyone
around ice not so much actually the
authorities but what other gangs because
everyone used these routes and they
can't be very very dangerous as a result
of that because your staff fighting
amongst themselves
the boy has paid $5,000 to cross he
hopes to change his family's fortunes
back home and they stumped up the cash
they move forward a quick wave and
they're gone the wall a dark line a
short distance away so heat sensors on
the the fence which is just there which
one Allah is going in the positive
dissipated as other people we think
coming so we've got here they didn't
want to skip right next to the fence
because do we be seen it's time to go
and then we're off another customer in a
multi-million dollar business delivered
despite appearances this is a lot more
sophisticated than simply a case of
jumping a fence
[Music]
it is through here that the cartels move
their cargo be it people or drugs
the vast deserts and tundra of northern
Mexico in the southern United States
divide the two countries its
inhospitable boiling hot for much of the
earth impossible to police and easy to
get lost in the 2,000 mile border is for
large sections little more than a wire
fence with a few bits of old railway
line welded together might stop cattle
but not much else you gotta be ready to
draw and shoot yeah it's like the Wild
West
it is the Wild West Jim Chilton is a
fifth generation rancher in Arizona
thousands of smuggled people and tons of
drugs are transported across his land
every year in fact he blames on the
failure of the authorities to stop it
essentially the Sinaloa cartel has
control this entire area
as you notice we haven't run into a
single Border Patrol agent that's
because they don't come out here they've
left this area basically available to
the cartel we're in their no-man's land
it takes two days to ride across Jim's
ranch a large section marks the border
between the United States and Mexico and
it's exactly because it's so remote and
large that the Mexican smuggling cartels
use it as their transport hub a hub with
its own supervisors and we found them in
the treeline
an overwatch position it's known as and
we sent our drone
they aren't happy we're watching their
Sinaloa cartel members net armed and
we're annoyed
that's a clear message go away
unexpectedly though two of the gang
stock coming down the mountain we don't
know why and we don't know if they're
armed
I got a code how are you cartel Scout
your cartel they confirm their Sinaloa
members from the cooler can the cartels
so what do you think guys here the guys
say these are the ones directing people
who say there's been 11 over here in the
last few days groups or 11 people it's
difficult to them I mean this is sort of
a crazy thing that we are divided by a
piece of barbed wire and it and some
railway track cartel scouts say they'll
be on the hill for the next few months
the matter-of-fact nature of the cartel
scouts going about their overwatch
business isn't lost on the US border
authorities they can't do anything to
stop them they know the smuggling of
people is incessant and they know that
the business while on the face of it
helps people achieve their dream of rich
in the United States it is in fact
lawless exploitative and very often
nothing more then it can't these are
very unscrupulous people they see
whether it's drugs or people as just
cargo it's a financial gain for an
illicit endeavor and it's very
heartbreaking for us to see that we see
people put through extreme temperatures
we're fortunate enough today that the
temperatures mild just a couple of weeks
ago with well over a hundred degrees in
most of our areas so people are pushed
through those areas at the hands of the
smugglers they dictate where people are
gonna cross and how they're gonna cross
and many times more often than not it's
a very difficult and daunting task for
the average person trying to cross there
the average migrant that might be
putting their hands and their life
and in the hands of a smuggler the sheer
numbers of people risking everything
even death chasing the dream of a new
life in the United States has turned
into a global epidemic the trafficking
syndicates are promising a cure to
endemic poverty and violence in
countries around the world are simply
profiting from the desire for a better
life we know the girls made it to Mexico
we were with them but where they are now
we don't know we probably never will
they could now just be another statistic
of trafficking crime
you